I pray that I see somebody front you
that would make me so happy
hi gods there's a seven pound piece of
pizza that's nothing to be pleased good
in me alright guys so it's my lunch
break at BuzzFeed right now and I just
found a seven pound pizza burrito in New
York and I'm making a video out of it so
I can get it for free and bus we can pay
for it
seven pounds I don't even think I weigh
seven pounds the only problem is the
place is an hour away so I get far so
why are you bringing me on this cuz
you're the food guy you ain't that like
biggest slice of pizza you eat the
spiciest curry
anyway pizza ice cream and and your car
so alright so this is a seven count
pizza burrito and we are splitting one
weird one each one each you honestly
think that you're able to finish it's
easy there's no way you a what like 450
yeah okay so I weigh nearly 75
pounds
so a seven pound piece of pizza that's
nothing to me yeah that's a huge it's
like a huge portion of your body weight
you waste so much more than eat that
you're probably way more conscious about
your weight so a seven pound visa is
like a way more stressful for you than a
district
Rousseau everybody
I pray that I see somebody finishing
that would make me so happy to know that
it can be done there's a lie and rely in
there I'm still feeling confident I
still feel confident
every time I roll it it still makes me
nervous that's gonna fall apart and all
my hopes and dreams are just gonna
shatter oh my god
hi guys this is uh this is big I just
want you to see how big this is
okay so you can see compared to my body
it's bigger isn't it thank you very
often forget when you see a challenge
like this that it's good tastes good I
am lactose intolerant I feel like a lot
of people are gonna be like oh it's a
pizza do you think it's a burrito I mean
it's definitely a rolled-up pizza but in
the same way that a burritos is rolled
up tortilla I don't know commenters
Sabrina getting this is an easy
challenge you see all this beats up why
does it look like I have so much more
than because I've eaten so much more
yeah y'all feel sick No
if you're really close
[Music]
are you kidding me oh my god oh oh my
god not knowing that done I've never
known a piece of Dietzen to be this this
is my match you're not happy with that
that's played out here today
[Music]
forgot to pay
- lizards or Blizzard sue is refreshment
we have to blur out the name Dairy Queen
No
it's not sponsored we're not sponsored
hey unsolved is on a new channel and now
your partner subscribed here that was my
part